actually also comes down to the kind of  dynamic in the relationship so even if  she is crazy if you have an iron fist  it's not going to be that much of a  problem if there is that Dynamic of  utter respect it doesn't matter how  crazy she is she knows she can't come up  to you and start shouting at you or  doing crazy [ __ ] because of the way  you're going to respond so as long as  there is that high level of respect  understanding the man's not going to  take it you have to just demean yourself  and understand that the man is the man  and you are the woman at the end of the  day so and a man's not going to take it  so if you are in that position doesn't  matter how crazy you are you need to  control yourself otherwise [ __ ] is gonna  happen